[Music]
foreign
manufacturer's protocol dictates I
cannot be captured previously on the
Mandalorian which in this instance means
reminding us of something that happened
over three years ago when you refer to
something this old it really just acts
as a spoiler for what we're about to
watch in this episode also making me
relive the brutal death of Taiko YT
Droid how can I atone according to Creed
one may only be redeemed in the Living
Waters oh and by previously on the
Mandalorian I meant previously on the
Mandalorian and the Book of Boba Fett
yep they buried the setup for season
three Amanda in episode 5 of season 1 of
Boba Fett dick move Disney but fear not
viewer the TV soon's recap service is at
your disposal here's what you missed
Boba Fett in the back to tank Boba Fett
whittling with Tuscan Raiders Boba Fett
in a back to tank again Amanda was
exiled for not wearing his helmet but is
told how to redeem himself Boba Fett is
the king of Tatooine you're welcome
thinking that replacing Ludwig
gorenson's epic opening theme with audio
from the episode will make me more
likely to hang around for the Star Wars
helmet orgy also do not Google Star Wars
helmet orgy or if you do tell them tvsen
sent you they'll know why and you'll get
a discount flaming hammering soldering
excitement
maybe this is the adult who has to pay
the bills in me talking but this fort
seems wildly inefficient I'm not sure
what kind of fuel you're burning to get
these 12 pillars of blue flame but if
you're only using half of them why not
turn the others off and dammit shut the
door we're not hating the whole
neighborhood you thought it we thought
it we all fought it which means the show
probably knew exactly what it was doing
by making this kid look like a young din
Jaren apparently Mando turning up to
save the day can be cool unless we don't
see it coming I swear on my name and the
names of the ancestors brainwashing
children the decent thing would be to
wait until he's an adult and can at
least decide for himself that he wants
to join your prohibitively controlling
religion I mean cult or Creed no I
really meant religion also does he get
another helmet after his next growth
spurt because at this age this one will
last in maybe two possibly three days
besides part of the Creed should be
having to suffer through wearing
hand-me-downs that are five sizes too
big to Jetpack practice now that's
character building From This Moment back
on I shall never remove my helmet never
we've seen Mando take his helmet off in
private to eat food and stuff so what
gives unless Den is inspired an offshoot
of the Creed which is even more
restrictive Mormon Deloreans
holy sh how quickly does this water go
from barely knee-high to able to
accommodate a giant [__] Sea Beast
and why didn't the armor close off the
beach weeks ago when Sheriff Brody
warned her also why are we holding a
religious ceremony at a body of water
where ocean crocodiles randomly attack
were there no other ponds or swimming
pools available
[Music]
imagine being a small army of
mandalorians and making this much of a
meal out of taking down a sea Beastie
they have [__] jet packs and medium
range weapons so why are they ever
getting close enough to get swatted and
or eaten I mean these [__] appear to
have entered the water during the battle
[Music]
um mandalorians the laces and bombs seem
to be ineffective so our next strategy
is to Rodeo this bad boy with our
grappling hooks
sir that doesn't make any sense it
sounds extremely dangerous I said Rodeo
time people yeah
oh
[Music]
okay now the armor is suddenly dumbass
too I know she smokes some Stormtroopers
with her hammer and talks back in season
one and it was totally badass but when
this creature is showing you the bombs
flamethrowers and lasers are ineffective
in what world is your next thought stop
Hammer time if there's one thing two
seasons in an episode and a half from
another show has taught us it's that
Mando kicks all of the ass and grogu is
adorable I really didn't need you to
sacrifice the first seven minutes of
your Premiere and the reputation of
Mandalore to reaffirm that if I visit
the planet and I can bring you proof
that I have bathed in the Living Waters
beneath the minds of Mandalore how's it
going to do that exactly take a Living
Waters bathing selfie I'm sure it's
possible but I'd also insist on seeing
that in private for like three to five
minutes for uh since research yeah since
research then by Creed the decree of
Exile will be lifted and I would be
redeemed which is information you
already know so why are you here this
entire conversation is almost copy and
paste what we saw during the book of
Boba Fett thereby angering the fans who
do consume every second of content by
repeat they've already heard my goodness
have we finally found a way to piss off
every Star Wars fan all at once
I know I'm supposed to be impressed with
this callback to the finale of rebels
but honestly I'm just annoyed I had to
sit through 75 episodes of rebels to get
this reference but also damn it this
show is so [__] gorgeous and and
grogo is so damn cute and and and I love
the space whales and and ah it's too
much my eyes my eyes
order agent's position please State the
purpose of your visit here to meet an
old friend you after reason that big why
even ask the question this is literally
the number one response in the big book
of what to say if you're here to do
something Shady especially weird
considering he's here completely
legitimately nice to see the sliceotron
Droid make a return but I don't really
understand its benefit in the street
market and these kinds of markets have
the produce ready to go and even if you
are chopping things up to order it's
hardly busy does he really need a Droid
to do it I think you've passed Peak
Droid when this is what you have them
doing
[Music]
in this protocol Droid is a walking
advertisement look I know a free market
will do whatever it's going to do but
any walking box with a speaker could do
this why use discount C-3PO the belters
are mining the asteroid fields at the
edge of the system belters you say
mining you say well that sure feels like
an expansive storytelling possibilities
you could rip off I mean be inspired by
you and the little one you can settle
down you can hang up your blaster except
you're about to ask him to be your town
sheriff so which one is it unless you
expect him to do so Blaster listen from
a farm in what feels like Ohio grogu
spinning himself in the chair is the
most adorable abuse of the force that
I've ever seen but it's still an abuse
go on tell me I'm a troll let the hate
flow through you but you're still
running around here with the same Little
Critter Pando just told you his name was
grogu so stop treating him like a
pointier gerbil remember when grogu used
Force healing to stop you from being
poisoned in the season one finale
exactly exactly so [__] you grief yeah I
said grief not nice is it I completed my
quest he returned to me oh you actually
wanted to see that crucial bit of
development well you guessed it that was
in the almighty book of Boba Fett too
I'm gonna look into how blackmailing
laws work in a galaxy far far away
because I think we may have a class
action suit here having an entire bowl
of just the orange ones it doesn't
matter what sweet treat we're talking
about no one likes the orange
onesies your timing couldn't be any
worse really you're basically catching
up with a friend and this is the worst
timing this car can ever drop a Pudu
while on duty
you it can wait
a group of pirates is threatening a
school and see derpio interrupts them as
if cargo's mom is bringing him his lunch
instead of oh I don't know saying
something like there are pirates trying
to get into the school then decide Roy
don't you know who we are my first guess
was that you're a d aged pre-tentical
version of Davey Jones from Pirates of
the Caribbean I had my money on the
X-Men being introduced before anything
else but I guess this was just as likely
I forgot it was your cut of my boss's
treasure that built this salute okay but
that's still his cut your boss doesn't
have anything to do with it once it
becomes cargas that would be like the UK
telling the US oh that's right it was
your cut of the colonies that built this
country wait now I'm confused about how
the War of 1812 plays into my poor
example that I clearly didn't think all
the way out
um I can always just in England again
Navarro will become the first truly
independent trade anchor in this entire
sector a free trade system wanting to
remain independent instead of allowing
yourself to be ruled by a government
from Coruscant you say I feel like I
watched 133 episodes from a series about
this very conflict what was it called
bone stores Zone horns cone tours I'm
sure it'll come back to me soon I need
him back we were lucky to recover any of
his Parts after he's self-destructed
right I mean let's Replay that explosion
and we're expected to believe that
anything was left intact let alone his
entire torso head and a whole arm why
was the entire explosion channeled to
his legs also the whole point of that
explosion is manufacturer's protocol
dictates I cannot be captured and this
looks pretty [__] captured to me also
also it is deceptively dark that the
people of Navarro chose to make the
heroes Memorial out of his salvaged
corpse instead of you know investing in
an actual statue
Only The Helpful lights on ig-11's had
give Mando just enough warning to get
grogu out of a potentially deadly
situation that he shouldn't have been in
to begin with
[Applause]
in the pilot episode it took one shot to
drop ig-11 here Mando hits him like five
or six times with that same Blaster and
he just keeps coming did the season
three writers not watch season one
no that's using your head Pedro Pascal's
audition tape to play the next James
Bond somehow makes it into the episode
challenge you to give me a better reason
for this weirdly out of character
one-liner he defaulted to his old
programming you think cargo would be the
magistrate at TV's High magistrate sorry
High magistrated TV sins ish they'll
have IG back to his old self in no time
IG goes from definitely only useful as a
paperweight to definitely going to be
able to help you on a dangerous mission
to Mandalore so quickly and I have to
wonder why we even bothered to blow him
up in the first place
I don't understand he said it's broken
Mando it's better English than I give it
the Dunkin Donuts counter first thing in
the morning and they still manage to get
my order right do these helmets need ear
holes what if I find you the part okay
you guys that's very different from
Rondo he said he can't fix it I can't
fix it is not I can fix it if you get me
the part galaxy far far away and yet
mechanics are still gonna mechanic
damn it favro once in off but that's the
last time this episode probably this
is conveniently tied directly of blocks
so that it could perfectly demonstrate
exactly what it does exactly what I
needed it to
I was gonna send the Avast thing but
then I realized we've had an entire
episode about Pirates without a single
Cameo from Hondo anaka and I can't help
but feel like if you're gonna bring back
CAD Bane you got to bring in Hondo or
else this Venture is no longer
profitable
his proximity alarm detected three ships
trying to Ambush them in an asteroid
field but it didn't alert them about
this giant ass Mothership until they'd
already seen it with their own eyes
really is tied into the plot isn't it
the internet or at least the noisy part
of it seems to have a problem with the
aesthetic of gory and Shard here
personally I've always loved Fraggle
Rock and would prefer this to CGI any
day yes internet this sin is for you
being too picky chill out wave that
thing around and they'll do whatever you
say the patriarchy also so he should
lead just because he won the darksaber
in a duel seems like dumb politics to me
almost as bad as relying on strange
women lying in ponds Distributing swords
as a system of government go home do we
really bring back Bo Katan just to mope
around in a castle and be mad at Mando
because if so I'd have rather had
another few minutes of grogu spinning
himself in that chair they're beneath
the Civic Center in the city of tsundere
the Civic Center Mandalore had Civic
centers are you sure the mine is there
and not under the fire station police
department or DMV also you could have
gotten this information from the armorer
at some point you have to the actual
Mission Mando not just mop up side
quests from your favorite NPCs
I'm not dead yeah he says he's not dead
yes he is
[Music]
we need
you
[Music]
all I asked for was a freaking rotating
chair I need an old priest and a young
priest
Mr Obi-Wan caught me doing this he'd be
very grumpy this is a school I call that
ball talk for a one
night we'll put down our Weaponry on the
count of three okay you ready I'm ready
one
two two
three
he said they don't make them anymore
they're very hard to find Tony Stark was
able to build this in a cave with a box
of scraps